I caught the controversy because like
there was there some in here that like
like obviously we want but like it seems
like I just realized this is me watching
Nova watching some other guy watching
Miley Cyrus 2018 everybody
[Music]
why does commentary content and
commentary culture in general appeal to
us it's very existence feels almost
counterintuitive why watch someone else
look at a meme or watch a funny video
when you could look at it yourself while
watch someone comment on the news when
you could watch it yourself I want to
try to answer these questions but in
order to do that I'll need to lay some
groundwork I want to rewind the clock
and look at streaming videos predecessor
television we watch what's on TV because
it shows us something beyond ourselves
beyond our sofa and our living rooms TV
gives us characters and people that
entertain us but we find them
entertaining because they're doing
things we are not the people who get to
be on TV and the viewer look very
different while the characters and
personalities on TV are doing
interesting things worth watching the
viewer is sitting at home in 2018
Americans watched on average 5 hours and
57 minutes of video a day many people
have talked about the potential problems
with these levels of consumption but I
think late author David Foster Wallace
was able to most clearly highlight the
problem I want to focus on today 6 hours
a day is more time than most people
consciously do any one thing how people
who absorb such doses understand
themselves changes becomes spec tutorial
self conscious the viewer consuming TV
at these levels starts to become
painfully aware of the difference
between themselves as a passive consumer
and the exciting interesting people that
they're watching advertisers begin to
leverage it's a viewers desire to be
more like what's on screen Wallace says
TVs real pitch in these commercials is
that it's better to be inside the TV
than to be outside watching the viewer
knows what's on TV is what's interesting
what's valuable otherwise why would they
be watching it but TVs glorification of
the noticeable individual is an implicit
condemnation of the passive consumer
currently sitting at home on their sofa
the reality that reality TV presents
will never represent the viewers reality
someone's viability as a subject for
reality TV is related to how
like the average TV viewer they appear
when we watch TV were happy to watch
people visit a restaurant talk about the
news solve crime but while you're
watching people do these interesting
things you by necessity
cannot be and when you're watching for 6
hours a day it's hard to make time in
your life to do those things that TV is
encouraging you to do by presenting them
to you as something worth watching forms
of streaming video like Netflix all have
the same problem as TV so how do you go
about trying to solve this inherent
condemnation of the viewer Wallis
himself was concerned with the irony
that he saw popping up on TV as a
solution to this problem but I think in
this era of online streaming video a
second solution has arisen Japanese
reality TV show and Netflix original
terrace house illustrates that solution
tears house is really two reality shows
in one in addition to the six housemates
the show features a panel of six
commentators who introduced each episode
and talked about what we just watched
happen in the house
[Music]
tonight while the drama on terrace house
is toned way down from similar American
reality shows the reality is still
idealized what goes on in the house is
not the viewers reality and it's
portrayed like a fiction the show
presents the image of the housemates not
with a voyeuristic wink and nod to the
camera but in a style we'd associate
with fictional dramas the house side of
the show creates the tension for the
viewer that Wallis identified the
housemates are usually attractive work
towards goals go on dates and generally
do things that are more interesting than
binge watching seasons of their latest
Netflix obsession but the second reality
show within the show relieves that
tension Terry's house provides us with a
panel of commentators who are proxies
for the viewers they are viewers of the
show and we get to watch them watch and
talk about what they watched this
appears to the viewer as a real reality
it's your reality or at least a better
mirror of your very reality while you're
watching the show than what goes on in
the house is the reality of this panel
is so obvious and so like our own that
even though the panel is the more unique
and unusual element of the show its
presence is never explained while the
premise of the house is restated in
every episode the ideal the panel
presents is one you can live up to while
you're watching your demo ami-chan got
to saw you never gonna tell uncle Murray
will you tell a meetin as high as you
take you know
the panel teaches you how to watch the
show guides your perspective of the show
and provides you with a simulation of
watching a show with friends but perhaps
most critically if we buy into Wallace's
theory it seems to validate your
existence and actions as a passive
consumer in order to be like the people
on TV you don't have to turn off Netflix
go make attractive friends do fun things
with them go on dates you can just watch
other people do those things and all you
have to do is judge and make comments
about their actions laugh at their
mishaps and express frustrations when
they do frustrating things and this all
must be valid because that's what those
people on TV are doing commentators have
long existed as part of TV but they've
almost always tried to present
themselves as being in a privileged
position they are on TV commentating
because they are experts or celebrities
some of the terrace house panel are
celebrities but they don't appeal to
that advantage to make their commentary
they are presented as the viewers equal
they sit not behind a fancy desk on a
massive set overlooking a fake skyline
but in a mock living room sitting on
couches and pillows as you might if you
had some friends over to watch the show
with you
much of online commentary content is the
same type of reality TV giving the
audience an on screen viewer in the same
way that Terrace house does these
commentators reinforce the ideal of the
consumer while allowing us to consume
the same content we wanted to before you
laugh you lose and other people's your
life you lose that's right we're gonna
react to people reacting to things and
see who laughs first and you're gonna
watch me reactiveness pudy pie presents
himself as just a bro in a room with a
computer watching stuff and playing
games not very far removed from what his
audience looks like when they're
consuming his content the passive
consumer is guided trained and comforted
by the commentary it turns out what we
wanted to see on TV all along was
ourselves but that's a problem because
we're boring the solution put someone
like us on TV alongside the content we
originally wanted to see
I want to be clear that this is not a
doom and gloom message about commentary
content what exactly it's doing and why
it's arisen is psychologically complex
and I'm only examining one possible
reason for why it's risen to prominence
recently in this video but there's a lot
more here and I don't think Wallace's
theory of TV's problem and commentary
content as a solution tells the whole
story in part two I want to discuss
commentary culture outside of streaming
video and how I think the medium of the
internet encourages commentary content
and I want to examine the role of the
video essay as part of commentary
content and why it might just be the
thing we need in the midst of our
growing media consumption and in the
spirit of talking about commentary
culture I want to try to integrate what
you have to say into this series so
leave your comment below and I might
include it in the next video maybe you
feel like you've been consuming too much
commentary content if you want to take a
step back and consume something
different and learn a skill while you're
at it I recommend trying Skillshare
whatever it is you want to learn skill
share has you covered with over 22,000
courses on a wide variety of topics
Skillshare is one of the best places on
the internet to learn or improve a skill
recently I've really enjoyed Aaron tre
plans courses on customizing type and
logo design they're entertaining and
I've learned a lot that has helped me
with the little bits of graphic design I
have to do for YouTube and video editing
Premium Membership for Skillshare starts
around $10 a month but for the first 100
people to use the link in my description
you can get two months of Skillshare for
free these usually go quickly so jump in
there while you can
and finally thank you to my patreon
supporters if you want to get one of
these little stickers and listen to the
podcast head over to patreon.com/scishow
Thomas flight